bonjour à toutes et tous depuis le début
d'été nous entendons parler de la
quatrième vague et de la seule arme que
nous avons très saine le vaccin au
moment où je vous parle il ya un peu
plus de 42 millions de françaises et de
français qui ont reçu une injection de
vaccin et il ya un peu plus de 35
millions d'entre nous qui avons reçue
est de dos et qui sont donc dû
m'invectiver complètement réussi que
c'est que pourtant il beaucoup parmi
vous s'interrogent encore ont peur
beaucoup entendre de fausses
informations de fausses rumeurs parfois
n'importe quoi il faut bien le dire
alors j'ai décidé de répondre
directement à vos questions à lui poser
les mois et les airs et d'être le plus
direct et le plus tard possible
à
[Musique]
où